title of this uh for those of you
listening is man in polyamorous
relationship with wife other man charged
with assaulting the other man this is a
recent story from about a week or so ago
in september
this is a washington a man in a
polyamorous relationship is charged with
assault and unlawful possession of a
firearm this is what often happens
um where is the story you said there
have been tension
so here it is uh he said the three of
them decided to go to bed as they were
laying in bed so this is a woman and two
men
uh bastan got up and said he wasn't
doing this anymore then left the room
the wife says she followed him out of
the living room which is when he pointed
a gun at her head and said that when the
men came into the living room and
stepped between her and passed on when
the man so this is the extra dude
she says bastard told the man take one
more step and i'll kill you the man said
he was able to convince bastogne to put
the gun down after pleading for
reasoning anyway so this guy's in
custody now there's criminal charges
this is just one story of a few that i'm
gonna show you
so it's not it's not all rainbows and
butterflies okay uh it's it's pretty
stupid here's another one now i've
covered this story a couple years ago um
there's an original version of this
where they just start talking about this
woman and her four
uh dudes again never alpha males they
look fat boy over here with the star
wars t-shirt uh she's holding this guy's
hand he doesn't look very pleased here
with his hands crossed in his lap
this is the
five
couple poly it's it's always almost
always one check and a bunch of nerds
and they're taking care of the house
paying the bills paying the mortgage um
sharing a little bit of time with her
maybe they play video games together
when she's out you know banging the
alpha males on the weekend because
that's usually what ends up happening
you know they end up taking care of the
house and the kids while she goes off
and pork some alpha male which i don't
know that she'd get one or not but this
is a situation this is this is where
we're at okay yeah moff makes a good
point she's 20 in this story but she
looks 40. now this is this follow-up
story okay this is a follow-up story
where they talk about her being pregnant
i'm not going to go through all of this
you can look it up this is her and the
biological father of the baby this is
her holding her stomach
although it's difficult to tell that
she's pregnant in that photograph this
is the
geeks playing cards at the table i guess
on car night so you get an idea now
they don't continue following this story
but here's i want you to look at this
guy's face over here let's see if i can
zoom it in a little bit
no it won't do it anyway
let's go
to this i want you to look at this guy's
face over here
this dude over here is the same guy
in this picture over here
what's the title say
again
this story here is about a polyamorous
florida woman with four boyfriends is
pregnant
follow-up story actually what's the date
on this
uh december 6 2019.
follow-up story
jacksonville man jailed in abuse of
five-week-old baby in 2020 march 2020.
this is the same dude over here
this geek over here okay
they don't talk much about it let's see
if they cover the poly part of the story
the girl's grandmother caught him doing
this distraught oh the horror
investigation broken ribs child
protection
uh
a child had a minimum of three attacks
baby's mother called florida department
children families
but uh
nothing mentioning the complexity of the
paulie relationship in this article
just green haired dude beats the crap
out of the kid that's not his again this
is him over here
so that's that's how that's a couple of
examples of how these things generally
unfold now i'm going to throw my earbuds
in because there's a video that i'm
going to play for you
of this four-way couple there's no kids
involved in this one yet but they're
talking about it i'm going to offer some
feedback on what i think is going on
because this is just insanity
share your wife and your finances with
your wife's boyfriend
what do we got here in the chat
uh rich why do you guys tolerate this
absurd behavior i wouldn't i would never
only only people with low options to
tolerate this sort of behavior
uh so chad says pure cuckoldry
all right so let's throw up this next
one in the stream here and get some
audio going share
screen tab
how a poly foursome so the title of this
is from cnbc
and it says how apolly forsa manages
their money
so let's see what we got here
uh
let's go this
so i've paused it over here at the 22nd
mark we've got kyle who's married to
rachel and we've got ashley who's
married to yair
kyle is a mixologist if i'm not mistaken
i think that's a fancy word for
bartender
rachel is a marriage and family
therapist
and ashley is a culinary director
i don't know what that means and yair is
a private chef now these two over here
own the house
these two moved into their house and all
four of these people share finances in
the house and each other
i think with the exception of the men i
think she plays and she plays with
everybody and the dudes don't with each
other but anyway so let's let's play
this and see what we got here from the
top
our nighttime patties i guess you could
say
i have my eye mask uh my evening lip
mask
sometimes i put snacks
yeah sometimes there are snacks
sometimes totally normal right you know
let's let's go through our bags and talk
about what's in them with our snacks and
you know blah blah blah of course you
know that's how they're going to kick
off the story because they want you to
think that this should be normalized in
society there are sex toys
this is kyle rachel ashley and yair
kyle's married to rachel and ashley to
yet ear two married couples in a
non-monogamous relationship a family of
four our sleep schedule is interesting
we go typically on a rotation
so you're gonna notice in this video
that this rachel
one now there's always a leader in every
group every tribe there's always
somebody that's more
of the leader role the alpha role you're
going to notice that she does all the
talking she's the one that collects the
money from all the people
and a few of them sort of chime in from
time to time so this would be
the i suppose a ring leader that
orchestrated you know most of this
um meaning like if it's from my point of
view let's say tonight's with kyle then
the next night is with ashley and then
the next night with the year and then
next night with kyle and next day so
it's actually the next next time here
and like kind of rotate that way
and the title of this is how to manage
finances in a non-traditional
relationship all right educate us cnbc
let's see what you got
we met at the very very very beginning
of covid uh we were all members of a sex
positive organization in new york city
there was a shocking it's new york city
a pull in me to message year it was very
clear that we had a lot in common and
hit it off and within 48 hours hey a
second this guy's a chef and he's making
like yellow mustard sandwiches
i don't know about that story anyway
hours i was talking with ashley who
messaged me i
thought she was absolutely gorgeous and
then was so excited after talking with
ashley for a day i realized that she and
kyle were like two peas in a pod so i
asked these two if i could bring kyle
into the group chat we started a group
chat of four people and literally from
that day we have not stopped talking and
now we live together and share our home
it is illegal in all 50 states
all right let's keep going
i don't i have a feeling we haven't even
touched touch the tip of the iceberg yet
to be married to more than one person
but according to a study published in
2021 one out of five people in the u.s
has engaged in a consensually
non-monogamous relationship at some
point during their life non-monogamy is
just having either more than one partner
or being open to having more than one
partner you don't have to be practicing
it to be it we share finances we share
our home a dog and a cat and all of us
and partners and partners a lot of
things we'll share like that jacket this
jacket no no no no no no this one this
one is you it's fun to be able to put on
something that like i would never buy
for myself or frankly even pick up off
the rack and she's like that won't look
good on me and like try it on did they
say how old they were
i don't know what like
yeah okay
yeah you're right i mean she's the one
doing all the talking so far and there's
there are some things where i'm like no
this is a this is an actually only
garment all four of their incomes go
into an account and those are the funds
they use to pay for everything together
i think that if we took a look at it
there would be
more
clothing than perhaps we are uh front of
mind aware of
so that's this dude's way of saying
you ladies are spending way too much of
our money on clothing
so
you're sharing your wife and you're
sharing your finances and you're buying
clothes for
somebody that's not your wife in a house
that you may or may not own i'm not
exactly sure how this is going to unfold
but let's keep going i mean this is this
has got to end really well let me just
check the comments real quick
yeah this dude's like this is definitely
not going to end horribly
uh i would love to see a follow-up story
in one to three years from now yeah this
is like
i've seen this movie before this is a
train wreck unfolding in slow motion
this is the title of this video should
be how to make a train wreck out of four
people's lives talk about what our
core spend expenses are what the bills
look like what the mortgage looks like
the interesting thing about this dude
yair uh mr tattoo here is he's got
what's called hunter eyes and hunter
eyes are you know you guys can google
this but they're
conventionally desired
um
i'm not sure if it's the balance or the
distance you know between the eyes but
but it's the depth in the brow um and
that's what determines that sort of look
and that's generally uh strongly desired
by women it's it's it's something that
they look for that's what evil psych has
concluded anyway keep an eye month to
month on what our numbers look like um
you know longer term you know we want to
do this next year what's that going to
look like will you give me that right
why don't you hold this so
mr tattoo arms here the chef now hands
over his money to
i'm
so she takes his money
[Music]
oh my god write the check for her too so
she can have a cash tip okay um and if
you want to give me the check i can i
also have a credit card if
that works
we really try to let everybody this dude
over here said nothing he's just sitting
here smiling like a muppet
live organically and do what they want
and then we come back and take a look
okay so last month i think we probably
overdid it on the restaurants why don't
we this month
you know trim that back and save up for
a birthday coming up in in next week's
or whatever
and as for the larger expenses yet
you're in ashley own the house they all
live in but the mortgage payment is
split
right so yair and ashley own the house
that they all live in but the mortgage
payment is split amongst all of them
that's not possibly going to end badly
in any way shape or form right i mean i
don't know what state law is like in new
york but i know for a fact that in most
places in the developed world if you're
making
installment payments on somebody else's
mortgage and you live in their house
then you have rights to
that asset if it doesn't work out now do
they have a cohabitation agreement or a
prenup i don't know let's find out all
four
one of the things that i was very
adamant about was that my student loan
debt did not come and impact
them um so that is something that will
not be on them at all and will remain
just in my name well that's very noble
of you rachel good for you except for
you're taking all of their money
that's not nearly the only difference
navigating finances with four partners
credit card companies um do not make it
easy for four primary account holders um
which doesn't make a gigantic difference
but it means that it
so he's complaining that credit card
companies don't make it easy for the
four of them to
run one credit card there's a reason for
that okay i come from the credit card
business they want you on the hook
for the credit that's issued now
legal agreements are generally written
for
an individual or for a couple they don't
have contingency in credit facilities
or instruments for four people 10 people
or anything like that like even in my
business like i have a
primary card and i have a secondary card
that i use with my brother
there's always a primary cold card
holder in secondary they don't have
contingency for primary secondary
tertiary and you know keep keep going
from there like who knows if they want
to introduce another couple or another
chick or another dude in this situation
um it just
just seems bizarre you know like why do
you need four people in a household
you're banging each other and you're and
you're mixing your finances into a giant
pot uh two of them own the house legally
the other two don't but they're paying
into it which would technically give
them the rights to the property if they
don't if it doesn't work out it's this
is just a massive recipe for huge
disasters just stupid it isn't the only
one person is getting full benefit of
that line of credit and getting a full
benefit of that um credit history so if
the four of us did want to be on a
mortgage in x number of years we
wouldn't all be getting the same benefit
um from carrying those lines of credit
it's part of when people talk about
feeling discriminated against as here we
go here comes the victim mindset i knew
it was going to come
whether it's sexual orientation you know
within the lgbtq community or in the
non-monogamous community um that's part
of what they're talking about is that
our entire system is set up for two
people i mean our system is not
reasonable and there's really no space
for other relationship designs
oh the bartender had something to say
what did he say
monogamy and there's really no space for
other relationship designs
that's why the two couples rachel and
kyle and ashley and yair have decided to
get divorced from one another so they'll
have more rates and benefits as a family
of four they're working with a lawyer to
create a cohabitation agreement
so they took vows till death do us part
in sickness and health blah blah blah
and then because
rachel
sucks them all into this vortex of
[ __ ] and moves into their house now
they all are getting divorced so they
can live as a foursome
so kyle and i remain married and ashley
and they remained married if something
were to happen to one of them and one of
us wanted to go see them in the hospital
we would have no legal right to do so in
a scenario where say rachel and i no
keep in mind they said at the get-go
that they all met each other
at the start of the pandemic which was
two years ago
so they've barely known each other for
two years they're already living
together
in this other couple's house they're all
getting divorced and they're now
creating a new agreement to govern their
finances and even things like who could
see who if somebody got deathly ill they
haven't even talked about kids yet let's
see if we get to that i have a child and
nobody's legally married if rachel and i
have a child
the protections afforded to ashley and
kyle as parents of that child are
difficult to get to if we start from
this place and move into these domestic
partnerships it makes it much easier for
the non-biological parents to act as
legal guardians and legal parents for
those children
beyond rights they say this cohabitation
agreement would legally define financial
responsibility among all four partners
it's really important to both me and
ashley to have a biological child if we
can um if we can't we have talked about
carrying the person's
you notice how this conversation is
you notice how they're sitting
and what the focus is
it's like rachel is the son
she's the sister son and then the two
dudes or accessories it's really
important to me and ashley to have kids
well what about the other guys
is it not important to them to have kids
or are they just accessories to go to
work and make money to pay for this
whole [ __ ] thing that you guys are
creating right now that's gonna
definitely implode on itself
egg that is viable and all of us will be
financially responsible for the
why wouldn't you be able to have kids if
you're young and healthy you know you're
talking about eggs and ivf and all this
sort of stuff this just this just reeks
man children and there will be language
that uh
explains what happens if something were
to go wrong and one person leaves
and no matter
how biological children are created
between the four of us i'm pretty sure
they're gonna have red hair it's in all
of our families
never mind who the father is
it's ah they're probably gonna have red
hair because it's in all of our family
so it doesn't matter if we just blend
all of our jeans like this because we
have nothing going for ourselves these
rights outweigh any financial advice
this is where we are married tax
benefits for one frankly the goal is our
lawyer is on the front lines of
creating domestic partnerships with more
than two people uh they were the first
person to
pass through a domestic partnership of
three people in a town in massachusetts
their goal is eventually having all four
of us in a legal domestic partnership in
the meantime we will have this
cohabitation agreement with potentially
a rearrangement for these benefits like
insurance and things like that
yeah there's no possible chance that
somebody's gonna lose their [ __ ] and
pull a gun or
hurt somebody else's baby like we saw in
prior examples this this is definitely
gonna work out really well for everybody
with all four like to ha like to deal
with one relationship with one check
comes with enough challenges on its own
let alone
two chicks and an extra guy in the
equation and you're blending all your
finances
this is just gonna implode the plan is
for the agreement to cover a lot more
too yeah no more than 30 a month on
video games uh if that's gonna be in
there that's on you
it's not gonna direct our budget you
know it isn't gonna be a you gotta love
the pie graph over here right
i
wonder
can we see now you can't you can't see
it i was wondering who's all
contributing to what and what they're
spending money on but you can't really
see it day-to-day finance document so
much as unfortunately so much as more of
a doomsday scenario document and um
a supportive document for things like
adoptions for things like uh greatly for
things like even dog care i forgot about
that one like they forced us to only put
one name down on a dog like the four of
us got together like there's
a lot of different places actually yeah
where um where it comes up so we're
hoping that um
that those legal agreements will help
this is all costing them more than ten
thousand dollars in legal fees so in
that way you know we are investing in
ourselves to make sure that legally
we're all set up as best as possible um
that's really not that much money for an
agreement like this but okay
and while they might not want to be
legally married anymore to lift some of
the obstacles they've been facing how
many how many shots do we need to give
of this dude giving this check money
he's giving his money
to this dude's wife
while they all pour it in and look at
these pie graphs over here or these uh
yeah basically a pie graph they're
showing their loving commitment to one
another in other ways
but rachel planned a very traditional
proposal situation with like a secret
photographer like a weekend away it was
really really adorable though the rest
of us in our different diads are talking
about um
different symbols and ways to
uh
yeah ways to use symbols be that jewelry
tattoos whatever the case is of um
solidifying those commitments with some
kind of meaningful symbol although i
wouldn't mind if he got down with me you
know
get down on one knee and propose to this
no pressure there are so many
assumptions and misconceptions about
what our life looks like one of the ways
to combat shame is to show people that
they're not alone and that it is okay to
be yourself so
i talk about my depression i talk about
being queer i talk about
oh there it is she's a marriage
therapist and she talks about her
depression
shocking
there it is
going to
sex parties i share so that people don't
feel alone and i share to destigmatize
and
frankly it also helps me
yeah
it definitely helps you that's for sure
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you